[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
salut tout le monde cette semaine une
vidéo complètement différent de
d'habitude puisque je vais répondre à
toutes les questions que vous vous posez
habituellement et comme je l'avais dit
c'est bientôt les vacances de noël et
après la grosse vidéo de spirou je me
sens légèrement fatigué ouais là tels
que vous voyez je me force à sourire
mais si vous regardez mieux grâce à ses
lunettes magiques qui permettent de voir
l'âme des gens regardez mieux à quoi ça
sert en fait voilà donc c'est pour ça
que vu ce mois ci on n'a pas le temps de
faire une vidéo complète et que ça
aurait été dommage de bâcler une vidéo
juste avant les vacances de noël parce
qu'on compte bien partir en vacances de
noël et surtout après la vidéo de
cheyrou et ben on a décidé de refaire
une grosse vidéo en janvier et en
attendant ce mois ci on va simplement se
contenter de répondre aux questions en
or aux questions que je reconnais ma
boîte chaque semaine et que j'ai ici
dans ce saladier
vas-tu tester ocarina of time avant
attendait de ce qu'on faisait pas
compris le principe de lait battu tester
super mario bros non mais attendez je
viens je vais te dire que je faisais pas
là tu as tu essayé de l'a64 c'est la
même chose qu'au final taille tu veux
tester sonic nord t70 non je veux tu
essaies tomb raider beaucoup plus de
monde cette semaine une vidéo
complètement différent de d'habitude
puisque j'ai décidé de répondre à toutes
les questions que je me pose à moi même
c'est parti est ce que c'est la vraie
voix de sébastien
mais bien sûr que non c'est ça ma vraie
voix qui est l'enfant qui fait le jeune
grenier je sais pas à free jeu le manque
est partie aujourd'hui des mois c'est
quand on n'est pas allé qu'est ce que tu
faisais un bon joueur du grenier c'est
très simple en fait je révisais des
films et et des pubs mais ça n'a pas
marché je sais pas pourquoi
donc voilà je veux montrer cette
troisième campagne pour lutter contre
les va la vie
fonctionnement sont visibles donc j'ai
peut être les meilleurs comme dit mon
docteur sarr au coeur et pij attraper
des maladies gens crèvent d'améliorer
son dealer et rim connu deux vagues
d'énergie du câblage et je chercherai
partout qui résiste un peu je sais pas
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ça n'a pas
marché
comment faire une bonne vidéo est ce que
tu as des astuces ou des conseils à
écouter on nous demande souvent
justement des astuces ou un making of
écoutez à défaut de faire un vrai making
of pour le moment et voilà déjà quelques
astuces que vous pourrez utiliser vous
aussi pour faire vos vidéos astuce tuner
le marchand d'armes n'avait pas de
moyens ne montraient pas le hors-champ
ce fut le délire magique qui permet de
ne pas montrer une action mais de faire
croire qu'elles se passent à côté en
utilisant les bruitages lancé par un
technicien
[Applaudissements]
cette astuce numéro 2 savoir justifier
n'importe quoi cette technique consiste
à faire croire à une grossière erreur
dans votre vidéo fait partie d'un plan
logiques et parfaitement calculé à
l'avancé
salut tout le monde cette semaine je
vais tester un nouveau jeu qui sera
certainement le à temps mais c'est flou
c'est parce que c'est un jour 10 6 allée
de mort cette semaine je vais tester un
nouveau jeu qui se passe à temps mais
c'est son séjour souligné l'étude ramasy
salut tout le monde cette semaine un
nouveau jeu qui sera certainement le
tableau micro dans le champ et c'est bon
là astuce numéro 3 et éviter les frais
encore
prenons par exemple eu de scènes lanta
je dis que je te parle
oui baby foot humain
attends je mette mes lunettes
quel numéro j'ai un stylo situe le
numéro
[Musique]
ça sonne
alors la rochelle voilà ce que vous
l'avez vu et oui parce qu'il y avait
effectivement un faux raccords dans
cette scène et oui le tiroir qui était
fermé au début de la scène est
légèrement entrouvert à la fin alors
faites attention à ce genre de détails
qui peuvent ruiner votre vidéo comment
tu cette chemise je sais pas pourquoi
tout le monde n'aime pas cette question
c'est super banal comme histoire du
parcours à l'univers mon fils tu
voyagera loin
mais nous ne quitterons jamais
toute ma vie passera dans tes yeux et
toute ta vie tu passeras aurait bien les
six dernières de père et le père à
devenir fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeudi à cette chemise et c'est comme ça
que j'ai eu ma chemise
voilà ben je l'achetais faut ce magasin
évidemment tu croyais quad est ce que tu
va tester marsupilami sur megadrive ben
écoute on avait essayé mais c'était pas
super donc le marsupilami pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est un animal jeune
qui peut faire plein de choses avec sa
queue merde alors pour tuer les ennemis
un par exemple le gars ne l'a donc il
faut appuyer sur a pour donner des coups
de queue qui merde
une fois que vous aurez récupéré le
bonus escalier vous pourrez durci à
votre que pour que grammaire est donc là
vous voyez pour effrayer l'éléphant il
suffit de lui montrer votre club pour
les temps mais bizarrement je sentais
pas celui-là est ce que tu as trouvé
pire que les doublages de camions yvan
tâche insurmontable simon sont ignobles
n'arrête pas de se multiplier sa perle
et complète un ver de terre jean labat
climat notre dernière chance j'espère
réussir si le maillot avant d'arrêter le
temps sera gris
regardez les voilà en fait à mazion
c'est bon d'avoir des régions
je te dis que ça ne marche pas jacob
sérieusement mais il n'en va se faire
les mollets
scrogneugneu toute la ville est en train
de s'affaisser leur séant ouais on peut
toujours trouver pire que penses tu de
l'évolution du jeu vidéo
ouais je pense que ça va un peu trop
loin quand même je veux dire genre le
jeu vidéo dépasse et de ça à ça alors
bon ok jusque là ça va mais après on a
voulu ajouter du louvre avec le motion
gaming après avec le kinect nous a
carrément voulu enlever la manette
chez moi c'est bon c'est c'est quoi la
prochaine étape on enlève la console
avant vous n'aviez plus besoin de
manette maintenant vous n'avez plus
besoin de console microsoft présente la
prochaine évolution du legs hennig en
exclusivité mondiale le ballon autonomie
illimitée la manette c'est beau la
console c'est vous jouez seul ou en
multijoueur avec vos amis sans limite ou
que la guide met aussi grand que la
planète entière
aucun temps de chargement des sensations
ultra réalistes sont époustouflants et
des graphismes proches du réel et
microsoft
le futur de tonnerre c'est maintenant
sortie mondiale le 29 octobre pré
commandez maintenant et recevez
gratuitement le premier dlc de petits
ballons
est-ce que tu joue à des jeux récents
oui pas beaucoup parce que j'ai pas
beaucoup de temps mais je vois quelques
uns par contre il ya un truc que je
reproche un peu c'est qu'on a trop
tendance à vouloir faciliter les jeux et
du coup mais ça fait un peu l'immersion
genre dans les fps modernes avant tu
stressé tout le temps pour trouver
médikid mais maintenant c'est fini ils
étaient pas ok maintenant tu te prends
un chargeur de kalachnikov dans le
ventre y'a pas de problème il suffit de
respirer 5 secondes et c'est bon c'est
reparti ainsi bien qu'on dit de l'air
pur c'est bon pour la santé mais faut
pas abuser
ou alors j'ai pas genre assassin's creed
par exemple tu le sais je sais pas c'est
un peu répétitif mais moi c'est
typiquement le genre de jeu que je
trouve trop facile quoi je veux dire les
garde dans ce jeu mais ils sont
complètement con ou quoi
c'est ça qui rend le jeu hyper facile en
fait moi je trouve ça assez fantastique
la manière qu'on les garde dans ce jeu
de tous venir se faire tuer un par heure
de combat
c'est super bien organisé en fait
on est j'ai une idée si on allait tous
en même temps faite à oued et moi ce que
j'aimerais surtout c'est que les mecs
ils s'achètent un [ __ ] de cerveau car
il s'agit de te retrouver hugues
[Musique]
oh
tom
attend dé lui non c'est impossible lui
des assises et wichser bas et a
complètement disparu
en fait on me demande des fois si je
m'énerve pour de vrai mais oui quand
même sur les jeux récents des fois ça me
fait rager tu prends chez pas le jeu le
plus calme par excellence va les sims
mais c'est horrible ce jeu tout est
énervant dans ce jeu tu attendes rien
faire tu te lèves tu vas aux chiottes
possible ces pistes pendant 30 minutes
chrono en main après tu vas à la cuisine
pour boire un café en bresse apprendre
quoi cinq minutes dans ce jeu s'en prend
si tu veux laver une assiette là c'est
une heure et demie ça c'est si tu arrive
jusqu'à l'évier parce que moi pour une
raison inconnue mais s'il adore poser
les anciennes par terre et si tu as le
malheur d'avoir mal placé un meuble ou
une chaise ouais les mecs se mettent à
râler pendant deux heures howlett
étoiles à réparer grippe est sous la
douche peut-être deux
enfin donc voilà ajouté donc moi moi ce
que j'ai fait pour me calmer dans
maintenant c'est que j'ai arrêté les
jours et ça en fait et je me suis mis au
simulateur allemand ces jeux je dirais
pourquoi est ce que j'irai jouer à
skyrim
quand je peux jouer à travaux routiers
simulator sérieux non mais c'est vrai
franchement il y en a marre de tous ces
éditeurs qui pense qu'on aura tous de
prendre pour des chevaliers je dire il
pense aux gens qui ont toujours rêvé de
devenir agent de la dde joie - le soir
car j'arrive
mais je pose des plots le long de la
route pour dévier la circulation et je
suis fier de moi un bon c'est pas très
utile dans ce jeu lui qui a pas de
voiture mais ce qu'il apprend des trucs
je dire moi je savais pas par exemple
qui ont utilisé un marteau piqueur pour
reboucher les trous dans la chaussée
moi j'ai toujours cru que quand tu
faisais un trou dans un autre où ça
faisait un trou plus gros mais je savais
pas j'avais tort et puis bon plus ce jeu
il est hyper réaliste un regard ça c'est
comme en vrai vient d'un club qui
bossent et tranquille branle rien qu'aux
membres et après tu vois des quand je
suis bien chaud je passe au simulateur
de la meuse de rues municipales aux
houillères alors là celui là tu vois il
arrache
c'est plus un peu
bien se fout bon je ne ferai pas de
commentaire sur le fait qu'ils ont
choisi de représenter votre personnage
avec la tête d'un vieil immigré
pakistanais mais en tout cas la fille de
ce jeu elle est géniale parce que mon où
il s'assura tu peux jouer le jeu
tranquille nettoyer les caniveaux mais
faut faire attention à ne pas toucher
les voitures ou hier pâtir de la moi je
fasse attention près de mabawa un [ __ ]
ce jeu il est vraiment trop réaliste bon
heureusement un sachet que les voitures
allemandes c'est comme les chats ça
retombe toujours sur leurs pneus et
sachez aussi que l'avs de votre
conducteur est lié à son véhicule un ça
doit être pour ça que quand un véhicule
est hors du bateau tu es tordu aussi
c'est ou alors c'est juste un bug mais
je sais pas rater un enfin bref en tout
cas j'ai plein de jeux pour mes vacances
de noël simulateur de chauffeurs de bus
simulateur de bûcheron de moissonneuses
batteuses de fourrière de livreurs de
cartons deux conducteurs de
transpalettes et simulation d'éboueurs
je vais passer des vacances de ouf sur
ma balayage bonnes vacances du monde
ludique
[Musique]